125-118 AND SWEEP THE DENVER
NUGGETS.
LET'S BRING DEVON BOOKER IN.
BOOK, THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME
WITH US.
THIS IS ERNIE JOHNSON.
HEY, SO, WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED
ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES TO WIN GAMES
IN THE PLAYOFFS?
>> I SAY JUST KEEPING YOUR
COMPOSURE, THE GAME WILL BE
PHYSICALLY AND HIGH INTENSITY,
BUT, YOU KNOW, STAY WITH IT THE
WHOLE 48 MINUTES.
THAT'S WHAT OUR TEAM IS MADE OF.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
STICKING WITH ALL SEASON.
I THINK IT WEARS A LOT OF TEAMS
DOWN WHEN WE PLAY LIKE THAT.
>> BOOK, GOING TO THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE FINAL.
IT'S OKAY TO SMILE.
TELL US HOW YOU REALLY FEEL,
BROTHER.
>> HEY, MAN, I FEEL GOOD.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD.
I HAVE BEEN WAITING ON IT 54 A
REALLY LONG TIME.
JUST PLAYOFF BASKETBALL IN
GENERAL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SAYING
I HAVE NOT PLAYED ANY MEANINGFUL
BASKETBALL AND I'M NOT READY FOR
THAT AND YOU KNOW, IT'S MY TIME
TO PROVE IT.
SO, WE ARE HAVING FUN WITH THE
TEAM.
THE WHOLE TEAM IS HAVING FUN
WITH IT, HAVING GREAT LEADERS
WITH CP, AND COACH MONTE HELPS
ON OUT A LOT.
SO WE ARE HAVING FUN WITH IT.
>> WELL, BOOK, NUMBER ONE,
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU HAD A
FABULOUS PLAYOFF RUN.
YOU STEPPED UP IN A BIG, BIG
GAME.
ANSWER A QUESTION FOR ME AND
KEN, WE HAVE A ARGUMENT GOING.
CP-3 BROKE AWAY ON THE LAYUP
LATE IN THE GAME.
CAN HE STILL DUNK?
?
>> THAT'S WHY I GOT ON HIM.
HE CAN FOR SURE DUNK.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE CAN DO IT ON
ONE LEG.
I TOLD HIM, YOU HAVE TO GET ON
THE RIM ONE TIME FOR US.
>> NUMBER ONE, ALSO, I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE COCONUT WATER,
BROTHER.
>> THAT WOULD BE NUMBER TWO.
>> COCOA5 COMING SOON.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> YEAH, I HAVE A QUESTION.
YOU GUYS WENT 8-0 IN THE BUBBLE
LAST YEAR.
>> HM-MM.
>> HOW MUCH DID THAT BRING IN TO
THE MOMENTUM OF WHAT YOU ARE
DOING TODAY?
AND IF YOU DIDN'T GO 8-0, DO YOU
THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
DIFFERENT SCENARIO?
>> I THINK WE BUILT A CULTURE.
I THINK WE WERE ONE OF THE LAST
TEAMS IN RECORD WISE.
WE WANTED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITY.
OUR GYM WAS GOOD.
AND WE DEVELOPED A CULTURE AND A
BROTHERHOOD AMONG THE TEAMS.
AND GOING IN TO THE OFF-SEASON
THE ADDITION OF CHRIS, JAE AND A
LOT OF OTHER GUYS FELL IN TO
WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW.
>> AND BOOK.
CAN YOU JUST PUT IN TO
PERSPECTIVE FOR US WHAT CHRIS
PAUL HAS MEANT TO YOUR GAME?
>> IT'S HARD TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE, MAN, IT'S SOMETHING
I HAVE TO LOOK BACK ON.
IT'S MORE HOW HE HANDLES HIMSELF
OFF THE COURT.
SEEING HIS ROUTINE AND SEEING
HOW HE GOES ABOUT HIS BUSINESS.
HE HAS DONE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT, YOU KNOW, ALL OF US WANT
TO REACH.
YOU KNOW, SO TO HAVE HIM ON THE
BACK COURT AND ON A DAY-TO-DAY
BASIS ON THE PLANE, PICKING HIS
BRAIN AND BEING A SPONGE TO HIM
HONESTLY HAS HELPED MY GAME
TREMENDOUSLY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, GOOD LUCK IN
THE WESTERN CONFERENCE FINALS.
>> YES, SIR.
I APPR